don't know if it's out where you are but
I do recommend seeing predestination any
chance you've seen predestination yet
Chris you should check out another great
aussie film from this year
predestination if you haven't reviewed
predestination could you please review
dude you never do a review of a movie I
want please can you review
predestination predestination
have you seen predestination yet
predestination predestination I've heard
you request to review predestination I
shall definitely check it out
predestination predestination
predestination predestination Stars
Ethan Hawke and Sarah snook and is a
film about hmm that's it's um it's a
little hard to sum up essentially Ethan
Hawke's character works for an
organization that's able to leap through
time to cause catastrophes from
happening in one particular part of time
Ethan Hawke plays a barkeep and someone
walks in and begins to describe their
life story to him and we see their life
story in the past and then some serious
mind-bending stuff happens I'm talking
confusing stuff and it's awesome I kind
of sort of loved predestination this is
such a different movie and a really
awesome sci-fi movie is directed by the
people who brought us Daybreakers also
starring Heath and Hawke which I thought
kind of flew under the radar and wasn't
too bad of a movie this movie however is
considerably better and goes in a lot of
really strange places that I don't want
to spoil for you guys which is good
because I don't even know if I can fully
explain it one of the things that I
loved about this movie were the
performances Ethan Hawke is terrific he
always makes interesting choices except
for get away I don't know about that one
but you know boyhood and the before
sunrise movies and that's all
good but I don't get away I don't know
what happened there I do love him as an
actor though and he was fantastic in the
movie but the standout is Sarah snook
she was so good and this is like a
star-making turn for her you can't take
your eyes off this girl I don't want to
spoil the twisty turn aspects of her
character if you don't know anything
about her character just go into the
movie and watch it I think you'll be
really surprised because for me I was
just like whoa that's something that's a
hmm yeah it's the kind of movie that's
so intriguing and sets up a plot that is
so interesting that you just want to
know about it and then once it ends
you're like I still am intrigued I still
want to know about it and you start
doing research and you start sifting
through message boards and all kinds of
forums and you really just want to talk
about this movie with other people to
see if they've had the same experience
with it that you have it's the kind of
movie like that where it just makes you
want to know more and it makes you want
to learn about its world and it makes
you want to investigate the different
metaphors and the hidden meetings and
the images and all types of things like
that that are all throughout
predestination that make you realize
this is a lot more of a cerebral
experience than you were planning to
have with this movie because I went into
it thinking okay Ethan Hawke Daybreakers
filmmakers it's gonna be a fun sci-fi
movie what the hell the action looks
great it's all filmed very well but for
me the thing that I loved about this
movie was the conversation between Ethan
Hawke as the barkeep and Sarah snook as
the person who comes in and starts to
talk with him that entire conversation
and that entire second act which is like
the whole almost entirely the first and
second act there's a little bit before
it that sets up the world but that whole
sequence
I found enthralling and riveting I
actually wish that that is how the movie
started though I wish that from scene
one it was Sarah snooks character
walking in and then discussing things
with him they do a lot of world-building
before that that I found was rather
unnecessary yes in the long run it is to
help you decipher things that happen
towards the end but as a film I feel
like there was a way they could have
just had it open seen one where this
character walks into the bar and you're
like okay because that would have been
just riveting like instantly because it
was so well done and that's one of my
only flaws with the movie I found the
film riveting it's mind-bending it
really makes you think it makes you want
to watch more and it's one of the best
January movies ever if you have a chance
to go see predestination definitely seek
it out I'm going to give predestination
and a - so between this and Selma there
actually are some pretty cool things you
can see this January what do you know
now guys if you saw my review for Selma
I mentioned something really awesome and
that is that I'm planning a new segment
it's going to be a segment entirely
about things that have inspired me over
the years I'm thinking the title is
going to be retro rewind
it'll be segments about one particular
thing it could be a book series it could
be a TV show a movie a game anything
really that impacted me as a lover of
entertainment or as a film critic or as
a writer or as a person and my first
episode is going to be up in a few weeks
and it's going to be entirely about
Toonami
Cartoon Network and now Adult Swim's
programming block that basically
championed and helped make anime famous
in the late 90s I have an awesome
celebrity guest that's going to be
involved with the video and I still
can't believe he agreed to it I'm fan
bowing out in every possible way I can't
wait to share it with you guys and I'm
hoping you enjoy it I'll be up in a few
weeks it's gonna be called probably
Toonami retro rewind something along
those lines and I hope you like it guys
thank you so much as always for watching
definitely check out predestination is
way better than anything in the January
release date so far that's for sure and
as always guys if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes